-Welcome to the show.
It is nice to meet you.
Thank you so much for coming on.
-Thank you for having me.
I've always wanted to do this.
-Yeah.
Yeah. Wow.
You did it right there.
Yeah, you -- That's it.
Thank you for
coming to New York.
I know you're probably coming
from L.A. or Australia.
-L.A.
-L.A., yeah.
Have you spent much time
in New York?
-I've spent a little bit
of time here.
I try to come sort of
as often as possible
to see the plays
that are on and everything.
But my parents are here,
and one of the biggest memories
I have coming here
was when I was younger.
And I came with them.
So this is one of my first --
-Where is your mom?
-I'm trying to find them
while I'm speaking.
-Oh, hey, there they are.
I see them.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Hi, mom. Hi, dad.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Yeah, it's also
their first time.
-Yes.
-It's their first time
being on "The Tonight Show,"
as well, which is perfect.
-We're in it together.
-When did you come to
the city with your parents?
-I think I was 8 years old.
And we sort of did all the
stuff, like all the sights.
And I remember my dad sort of
surprised me with tickets
to a Knicks game, because I was
a big basketball fan.
-Oh, yeah, and where did --
-Yeah, we were in
the nosebleeds, up the back,
but I remember it was just,
like -- It was, like --
It was the most special
experience, though.
You know what I mean?
-Don't you have some news
to tell your parents?
-Yeah. We're going to the Knicks
tomorrow, but way closer.
[ Applause ]
-Yeah, that's right. Way closer.
-Yeah.
-Now, the new season
of "Euphoria"
had a giant premiere on Sunday.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-It's become a huge, huge hit.
Did you have any idea
that it would be this big
the second time around,
the second season?
-No, I didn't know, and then
they told me this morning
that it, like,
crashed the website.
And, you know, a lot of people
have seen it, so it's -- Yeah.
It's so scary.
-I'll tell you what's scary.
You're getting your own
wax figure at Madame Tussauds.
-Yeah.
-Now, I'm lucky enough to be --
I've done it myself, as well.
Have you been through
the whole process yet?
-I did.
I went through the process,
and it was strange,
but the strangest thing is their
shirts that the crew wear
say like, "Paparazzi"
and like, "Celebrity."
That was the
strangest thing for me.
Like, you've got all these
cameras in front of you
and you've got all these
little dots on your face.
It looks like behind the scenes
of "Planet of the Apes."
And then these people
in shirts that say like
"Paparazzi"
and like, "Celebrity."
-Really? I didn't see that...
-Yeah, it was peculiar.
-...on mine.
-Great people.
-I don't know if you have
legit people doing it.
-It's like a gang of paparazzi
just, like, lured me in --
-Taking your picture, yeah.
It turns out your
wax figure is this big.
-Yeah, it's a bobblehead.
-It's LEGOs. Yeah, exactly.
This show, "Euphoria,"
I will say,
is pretty dark at some parts,
pretty, you know --
It must be stressful
to do a show like this.
But I heard that
to keep it loose,
you would do you this thing
where you would grab
people's phones and just take
selfies with their phones?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Now, how do you go with that --
I like the bit,
but what is it?
-Well, it's not even, like,
"Euphoria"-specific.
I think was in New York a couple
of weeks ago and I was at a bar,
and someone had left their phone
sort of on a table somewhere.
And I kind of just, like --
There's something about it.
Like, I want them to find it.
I have this idea
that they're going to have
the phone for like 40 years,
and in 40 years' time,
they're going to be like,
"Oh, I'm going to go through
my camera roll,"
like they don't
go through it every day,
and be like, "Oh, my God.
Who is this?"
-No, they know who you are.
But you just grab
a phone and just --
-Yeah, like,
but I don't move it,
because I don't
want to be invasive.
So I do the slide up.
-Oh, that's very nice of you.
I appreciate that.
Yeah, thoughtful.
-Yeah, like a pigeon.
-Yeah, very thoughtful of you
to do that, yeah.
In this show,
you play Nate, who --
He's not really a good guy.
No.
But at the end of
Sunday's episode,
your character is
a little changed kind of.
Well --
-Yeah.
-He gets beat up.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-But fans were like,
"Well, he had it coming."
-Yeah, they were stoked.
They were so happy about it.
-And would you agree with that?
-Well...
-I mean, it is you.
-I think me as Jacob,
I would love to beat him up.
Like, I would love to give him
a clip around the ears.
But as Nate, you know,
I feel very bad for him.
-Yeah, because you are
his character.
You're playing
the character so well.
-Yeah, I had to get beat up.
-Yeah, and you don't want to get
beat up, but --
-It sucked.
-Yeah.
-You look fantastic.
-Thank you.
-Thank you for coming
on to the show.
I appreciate this.
I think the last time I saw you,
you were with your dad.
Your dad was on our show.
-Yes, and that was a very
embarrassing day for me.
-Why was that embarrassing?
-Well, I had just gotten off
the flight to see my dad
and I came here and I,
like, looked disgusting.
And I was just, kind of hiding
in the dressing room,
and my dad's friend was like,
"Oh, do you want to go upstairs
and, like, check out
the 'SNL' floor?"
And I was like, "Sure.
Like, hope I don't run into
anyone, whatever."
Harry Styles was hosting,
and I knew that, but I --
I was like, "There's no way
I'm going to see him, right?"
And then, the first thing --
Like, I walked into the room,
and he was right there.
And I literally,
like, could not --
Like, I went into shock.
Like, I didn't even know
what to do with myself.
And then I --
Yeah, I just went into a panic
and then I got back down
to the dressing room
and started hysterically crying
because I was so overwhelmed
and just not expecting that.
And then you
knocked on the door.
And I was so humiliated
and I hear like,
"Hey, Judd, it's Jimmy."
And I was like,
"Oh, no, no, no!"
And then I -- Yeah, so, then I
just turned and faced the wall,
like, thinking, like,
maybe if I turn around,
you won't notice I was there.
But the room was really small.
-Yeah.
-So, yeah, and then
you saw that I was crying.
And I was really humiliated by
that for like -- And I still am.
Like, telling it, I'm like,
"Why am I telling this?"
-Oh, no, I didn't -- That's
normally the reaction I get
when I say hi
to people backstage.
You weren't crying tonight,
I will say that.
Backstage, you were not crying.
But why were you nervous
for Harry?
Just -- Didn't you interview him
or interview One Direction?
-Yeah, I did interview
One Direction when I was 14.
-Now, what was this -- How did
you get a chance to do that?
-I don't even --
I had a popular Twitter page
when I was like 13.
-Uh-huh.
-And I decided I wanted
to become a child journalist,
and they asked me
to interview One Direction
on their first trip to America.
-Wow! And so, that must be
nerve-racking.
-Yeah, it was, like,
the scariest thing in my life.
-Yeah, and I know that you were
freaking out before you --
right before you were
going to interview them.
And you were -- You were upset,
but your dad videotaped you.
-Yeah.
-Well, we talked to your dad.
And we have a video.
If you don't mind us
showing this,
this is 14-year-old Maude Apatow
preparing to interview
One Direction.
Here we go.
-Ooh!
-In 10 minutes, you'll be
in the room with One Direction.
Let's go!
-[ Shouting indistinctly ]
[ Laughing, wheezing ]
-What is that?
-I couldn't even say words.
Like, they're just --
They weren't coming out.
-We have a picture of you, too,
minutes before
you were interviewing them.
Look at you.
You're so emotional.
I mean...
[ Cymbal crash ]
Oh, my gosh.
Yeah, that was you.
But then this is you actually
interviewing the boys,
and you did a great job.
-I don't know if I did
such a great job, honestly.
-Oh, really? Was it bad?
-I don't think--
It couldn't have been good.
-Would you ever listen to it
again or play it back?
-No.
-No, of course not.
No, no, no.
-God no. No, no, no.
-Well, shortly after that,
you got to see One Direction
in concert.
Your dad told us this.
-I did, yes.
-And that must have been fun.
It probably went -- You probably
weren't nervous then?
-No. It was worse then.
-So, we have a video of you
right after the concert.
[ Laughing ]
So, you saw the concert.
You had a great time.
-Yeah.
-And then,
this is after the concert
with your family
and your sister.
And here's -- Yeah, take a look.
-[ Sobbing ]
-Maude, you're fine.
-"Maude, you're fine."
-Oh, my God.
-You have good parents
to send that video to us,
so thank you to --
We appreciate that.
How is the family?
Everyone good?
-Yeah, everyone's great.
-Alright. We're fans.
Please say hi
to everyone over there.
I want to talk about "Euphoria."
This is a...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...massive, massive, massive hit
on HBO this season.
Bigger than anything
in the world.
And everyone was
talking about it, like,
broke ratings records,
all this stuff.
But it's more finding
the backstories
of a lot of
the characters on this one.
Now, what can we expect for your
character, for Lexi?
-I think you'll see a lot more
of my character this season.
I don't know if
I can even say anything.
I'm going to get in trouble.
-Yeah, I know.
-But it's all exciting,
and I think people
are going to be surprised.
I think, like, people think
my character is sort of
this shy, like, sweet one,
but I think she might be
just as crazy as everyone else.
-Oh, my gosh. No, you're --
-No, she's not.
-Alright.
I don't know
if I can handle that.
You were telling me,
though, backstage
that every shot is
very technical on that show.
-It is very technical.
So, they'll, like,
do these long shots
where they don't make any edits,
so they'll have us, like,
walking through
the school hallways,
and it will be like
two minutes without any cuts.
So if you mess up,
the whole shot is destroyed,
and I always mess it up.
So then, yeah, basically --
-So if you mess up,
everyone has to redo the --
-And it became,
like, a running joke
that I would always
miss my mark.
Because they put,
like, a tiny, little piece
of tape on the ground.
And you can't look at it,
because then it's obvious
you're trying to find it.
-Yeah, that is true.
So you just have to,
like, zone and find the mark,
and you'll be like -- So,
they'll do the tracking shot,
and then you got to be like...
"Hey --" You know, whatever.
-Exactly!
-And they're like,
"No, over here."
And you go, "Oh, yeah."
"Hey!"
-I'm always like
10 inches off of the mark.
-Just a little bit off.
-But then they were like --
They started putting, like,
sandbags and boxes so I would
just, like, knock into it.
-You have to walk into a wall
to hit your mark?
-Yeah, it still didn't work.
-Yeah, I had one line
in "Band of Brothers,"
this miniseries on HBO.
And Tom Hanks was directing.
And I had to drive
a World War II Jeep
and then say like, "Hey, boys,
I'm getting the ammo"
or something.
And I go, "Great, let's do it."
And they go, "Oh, we got to wait
for it be nighttime."
I go, "Nighttime?"
And then he goes,
"We got to get the extras."
And they had 200 extras.
I had to drive through
all these soldiers
trying to find my mark, where
I'm driving a car to my mark
and then say,
"I'm bringing ammo."
And I was maybe
like a mile off the mark.
So I drove in
and then just parked.
I go, "We got ammo, boys!
We got it."
And then Tom was way over there.
I was like,
"Where is everybody?"
He was like, "Dude,
you're way off the mark, buddy.
Can we replace him right now?
He's so bad."
But you were phenomenal in this,
and everyone is buzzing
and talking about you.
Congratulations
on all the success.